benvenuti a grande fratello
siamo tornati sono tornata dopo 15 anni
e il cuore batte forte forte molto forte
visto che al cuore bistocchi al cuore
giuro ma non può partire questa edizione
senza salutare prima i miei tua tronisti
li ho voluti a tutti i costi sto
parlando di cristiano giorgio che sono
gli addetti mille sono molto vividi
ciano venissimo di vertici palla queste
diete e simona izzo ciao barbara volevo
ringraziarti tantissimo per avermi
voluto in questo programma lo sai che io
ti stimo immensamente la reggina
finalmente tornata una pausa ad ora sarà
un grande fratello non molto divertente
ma con storie anche molto forti
fortissime di personaggi che che ne so
magari alice questo in qualche
trasmissione
ma partiamo subito con la prima del
primo concorrente lucia bramieri 57 anni
milanese doc eccentrica schietta non le
mando a dire se mi schiaccia il piede
non ti porgo l'altra guancia
tutti mi conoscono come la signora
bramieri in quanto sposato l'unico
figlio del grandissimo gino io sono
stata una delle prime vigilesse del
comune di milano ore ore sotto la
pioggia sotto sole con una divisa
tremenda non potevo neanche scegliere la
fit
io non uso il cognome bramieri
io sono la signora bramieri piaccia o
non piaccia
fatevene una ragione allora abbiamo
appena visto la prima concorrente e non
so se lo si è questo è questo elicottero
che sta girando sopra la casa
ebbene sì è arrivata la donna la chiamo
uragano lei è un uragano che arriva
dalla spagna
avete capito bene sto parlando di arida
già paura italiani 6 pronti
sono arrivata al grande fratello 6
pronti
andiamo in italia pronta per una donna
come aida lasciami inginocchiarmi per
baciare la terra di questo affascinante
poi lasciami credervi che questo sogno
che è diventato realtà che aida nizar
una donna travolgente una donna chi ha
voglia di vita una donna piena di
passione
aida è una star e la spagna tutti la
gente mi ferma perché hanno bisogno di
una foto con me il mio e scopo e farvi
innamorare il team arrivo grande
fratello vieni vieni no vabbè credo di
non potercela fare
avrete già intuito di cosa stiamo
parlando ma il bello deve ancora venire
visto per far entrare nella casa del
grande fratello 15 air avvistamenti
grazia barbara grazia non batterà una
vita per ringraziarvi per questo sogno
tu barbara sei un angelo sami
inginocchiarmi baciare la terra di
questo bel paese
non possono meritarmi che questi
italiani questo aspetto io non sono
abituata perché naturali sempre lottare
per il sogno che riesce sempre a grazia
l'italia non sarà più la stessa costa
una volta chiave unitaria una comune
come una mossa la riparazione italiani
dovete promettere a me che adorate la
vostra vita noi adoriamo la nostra vita
perché aiuta una donna travolgente una
tradizionale barbara una cosa solo aiuta
perché questa è la gente che vuoi
chi comanda polizia il mio capo io
lavoro per poi questo io non parlo
e io sono una donna che è piena di
passione questo grazie a molti italiani
un aiuto arriva ascoltami allora conosci
cristiano malgioglio
io sono con 8 al cuore di questi
affascinanti italiani ma chi è questo è
il fratello dello zar ma dai ma come di
per me questa roma c'è e chi ti conosce
io sono come ti permetti tu chi è questo
è un altro concorrente che mi vuoi
prendere il post fare allora va allora
io sono l'ultima cosa io sono volevo
dire una volta per tutti che tutto il
mondo ripete in occupazioni prego entry
la settimana prossima
devo fare la devo entrare assolutamente
a era deve entrare ora subito bloccati
vi prego castigatore dalla prendere
blocca io non ho più tempo devo chiudere
vi prego non ho più voce ve lo giuro
devo chiudere fatemi sapere con un
commento qui sotto
se volete una nuova puntata di questo
grande fratello 15 e come al solito
ricordate che dopo i miei figli
nel mio cuore ci siete sempre voi col
cuore
adoro col cuore
ma ho il cuore soprattutto questo non
vedevo l'ora stava soffocando